it ends in both the show and the game
with Joel lying to Ellie does Ellie
believe him yeah how cool I don't think
she does but she has to force herself to
believe him and it not being true is too
painful uh so I think that she like
forces herself to
to believe him and like buys into her
own delusion she has to for her own
sanity what do you think Ellie would
have done given her own choice in the
matter as soon as she found out the news
that she was immune and like possibly
held the key to providing a vaccine for
the world like that's when she felt for
the first time that her life mattered
given the choice I don't think she'd
even think twice she would she would do
it every time